foreign
welcome back to another video by simply
learn this is anubhub and in this video
we are going to create this interesting
WhatsApp clone using react.js but before
we begin if you haven't subscribed to
our Channel already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and press the Bell icon
so you will get all the updates from
Simply learn so without further Ado
let's begin and create this interesting
WhatsApp clone from scratch but first
let me tell you what react.js is
so what is react yes react is a
JavaScript library that is used to build
mobile and web applications fast and
Interactive it is an open source
reusable component based front-end
library of JavaScript react is a
combination of HTML and JavaScript which
provides a re-burst and opinionated way
to build modern applications now let's
jump to the coding part and start
working on the WhatsApp clone now let's
see how WhatsApp looks like so this is
WhatsApp app
and you can see we have two components
one is this component which you can say
like chart component or this component
which is just for dummy purpose but
whenever we click on any chat from here
it'll just open the chat here in this
component so we can
name it as container component and this
as contact component contact list
component okay so let's create this
amazing app just open your Visual Studio
code all the code will be done in this
editor so let's
close this first
let's close this let's press Ctrl plus
backtech and the terminal will be open
you can also open the terminal from here
just go terminal and new terminal
terminal will be open so as you can see
there are two are terminals so I have
deleted one
so let's create this app
let's write npx
create
react
app
and then the name of the folder which we
want to create
so I'm going to write WhatsApp
clone
okay
let's press enter
let's wait a couple of minutes
so all the files modules libraries get
installed okay
it'll take a couple of minutes
just wait and be with me by the end of
this tutorial I am sure you'll love the
output because we are going to create
exact same copy of WhatsApp
it'll take few minutes
now as you can see our react project is
installed so what we are going to do is
let's see the WhatsApp
clone enter
um now we are in the WhatsApp clone so
we'll write npm start to see whether
this react predictor is working fine or
not
now
so this react app is installed okay now
what we are going to do is we are going
to just
open the folder
so this folder is in my C drive you can
just see the path from there
where it will show you where the folder
is created
now
a WhatsApp app is open now I'm just
going to open this
so in this I'm not you going to use the
testing component so I'm just going to
delete this okay
and this also and this common we don't
need okay let's save it
let's close this
file
now I'm not going I'm going to open this
app.js
okay
inside this I don't need this part
also I don't need this
and from here
to here let's leave this header
and let's just
do this
let's write
H1
simply learn
so
and this I'm not going to use the
CSS I'm going to use the style
components so for that let's open the
terminal again
here I am going to write npm install
components
okay press enter
it will take more couple of minutes so
let's remove the files that we not going
to use in this project
so I'm not going to use this
also this
this
and this
okay
so let's just delete this
so
this will be the structure of our file
now
now let's open the index.js we don't
need this
let's remove the client from here
let's save it
now what we are going to do is
let's just
rework on this
let's write react
as we are working with react router
window
and this is in the function
everything will be
now let's just
root the elements
by just clicking
document
dot get the element
by ID
and then
root
okay let's save it
okay
why it is showing this
oh yeah
now it's fine yeah let's save it
let's
yeah
let's remove this part
now and next dot JS is ready okay
so this app
.js we are going to do all the work
let's just remove this class from here
we can just add it after some time
we don't need it right now
okay
yeah fine let's save it and see the
output
we'll just start the development
yeah
so as you can see it's showing simply
long
now let's Analyze This WhatsApp app okay
so this is divided into two parts okay
one is this component and the second one
is this component
let's create this component first
inside this Source let's create a folder
called components
okay
and inside this
let's create two files
let's name this one as contact list
okay let's write components also
Js
I'm not going to use the CSS because I
already told you that I'm going to use
the style component which is installed
okay the second one is conversation
let's fit components
dot Js
okay
small mistake
yeah
fine
everything looks good now
okay
now let's open the app.js and install
for import
the style component which is installed
okay
now let's create our first container
container
Style
dot Dev
and
bucket
okay
yeah
now inside this I am going to write all
the style components you can also use
the CSS file it's fine
but here I'm just going to use the
style component okay
so just be with me
and you'll love the output I'm sure
so let's write Flex
Direction
which is row
fine
let's write 100
oh yeah
it's showing an error let's see what's
the error here
so it's just saying container is saying
the value but never used so we are
assigning the values to this container
okay but we are not using it right now
we'll use it here but let's just finish
it first then we'll use it okay
let's give it a height
of 100
percent
okay
let's give it a background so I have all
the code of the back colors
you can just copy the source code will
be in the description box no do not
worry about that
so
I'm going to write f8 F9 and FP
let's save it it's showing the same
error don't worry about that
now let's delete this
okay
now
as we are going to create okay no
let's just return
container
now inside this container I'm going to
write
hello from
simply learn okay
so
let's see the output it's showing hello
from Simply learn
right
okay
let's move forward
with the code
now what we will do is we'll work on
this contactless component
okay
let's create another component
or the
const
contact
list
components
not components but
its component
the name of the folder
okay
so
I create a function with fat Arrow
function inside this
we are going to return
uh
contact list
it's just a simple step do not worry
about that
opponent
let's now
export it because it will not export the
component will not work
let's write
okay this
let's
save it
now coming back to app.jss
m.js
here and after the container
I'm going to add one more thing which is
contact
list component
but we are not going to write this
either
this this is also fine that was also
fine okay
so let's open it
as you can see it's saying
here and this here
so we need to give the assigned space to
both of them
this one and this one so do not worry
about that also
let's first
this has already been added
okay
now
let's copy this
paste it here
rather I'm going to write
the other
conversation
component
conversation let's just save it it's
showing an error because
we haven't
done anything yet
now let's just copy this and paste it
here
change the names
and
here also
and
exporting
and thinner okay
is defined but never used we'll use it
if it's just
telling us again and again so let's use
it right
okay
it's looking fine all the three
components are here contactless
component
container component and this is just a
dummy text
coming back to the code
now let's remove this hello from Simply
learn
okay let's save it
coming back to this contactless
component
I'm going to create a container
okay
let's create a container but first let's
import style components
okay
this
let's create
const
container
inside this and again I'll do the same
style dot Dev
practice
in display
which is
legs
okay
after that
legs Direction
which is
column
I'll show you why we use this column
because
all the chats are written column
positions so that's why I'm using the
column part okay
so
let's move forward
okay
let's give it the height
now what else we can do is
let's say no value would never used
okay fine what does it say
okay inside this return
let's remove this and let's write
container
close it
let's copy this close bracket and paste
it here
and okay
that's right here
and here
now let's save it
and it's successfully installed now
let's see
oh nice
as you can see
that's successfully
okay
now let's give this as
Flex because we also sometimes resize
the window
okay
let's add once little space here
yeah looking very good
here
we have that everything fine
let's
fashion
okay
let's just see here
now
let's work on this
component okay
here what we'll do is
will again create first import the style
component
because we are going to use it
import style after that
let's give it some space here
now we will write
const
container
again we are doing the same
I just get some styling
nerve
and then the back tick starts
here I'm gonna write display
we
spline no yeah
flicks
okay let's just leave this
now
we'll lose Flex Direction which is
column because
all the things will come under this only
Now red light height which is again
hundred percent
and now
Flex
Flex should be here
let's write 2 first then we'll check and
see it's showing okay fine
now let's remove this
inside this container
right
let's copy it from here
paste it
save it
showing an error let's see okay
closed
yeah everything looks good let's save it
and see
yeah
so let's divide it evenly
so this is taking this much of space
okay let's give
eight
okay
yeah it is fine
this from here
we're going to create this part and then
that we are going to create this
okay
yeah this looks good
okay fine let's move ahead
with the
functionalities
okay
now
let's add let's just first see what
we're gonna create first thing we are
going to do is we're going to create
this part okay where the image is
looking
so now I'm giving you one task okay you
have to add these four icons I'm not
going to do that for sure
you just have to do
add these four in your app
so how you can do it I'll tell you but
you have to add that isn't it
interesting okay
so just open the
icons for react
okay
so you have to first install
these react icons in your system after
that you have to work on it okay you
have to work on how to find the icons
so here you can find unlimited of icons
which icon you want okay
let me just find one for you so you can
get an idea how to add the icons
so
as you can see there are it's a
messenger
okay let's
just find one few ways
then you can just add all the others
okay
here you'll find every icon do not worry
about that
so this is one
but this is
vertically so let's
find it again
let's search for it right
it'll be a very amazing you can search
on internet also or you can just go to
here
inspect
add the SVG file
yeah
you will find here the SVG of this
okay
right now it's not
yeah
okay
so here
you will find this SVT
you just have to
copy this
copy element
just I'll just show you
just paste it and then
just
click on it
and just
format document
configure I don't want to configure
right now but this is how you'll do this
okay
you just have to go to this form and
document
and then it'll be formatted okay
now coming back to our code
we are going to do is let's cut this
you'll get an idea how to do it okay
so I'm going to add create this part now
which is contact list
component right
now move ahead
let's
create
const
profile
looking for
Belling mistake shouldn't be here
so just
write
carefully okay
let's write style dot Dev again
backtech
yeah
yes download there
let's
add here display which is
Flex
Direction
row because
the image we need is here so this is the
row this is the columns
so one two three four I'm not going to
write it leave it and I'll leave it for
you guys
okay
huh
that'll be very interesting if you'll
work on your code
and you'll learn so many things okay
I can also do that but okay I'll I'll
add this part and
code which will get in the description
box
so
I'm going to write
the color
for the background
and then I'm going to give
heading
because I don't want the
picture to be looking
I have to add this don't worry about
this
here
in the public folder I have added few
images like this ah this image and some
other images
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create
one folder inside this
and let's name it as
profile
okay
inside this I'm gonna add a few pictures
so to copy one
two
let's drag and drop it inside the
profiles
oh no
let's see the images are coming right
okay
yeah so I'm gonna add few more images
so I have added few images like this
just dumb images
if you are mine and fewer dummy okay
let's open this contact list component
here we will create close this first
now let's create another one
let's write const
profile
image
again style Dot image
okay
let's give it a width
a t
30
and the Border radius
50 percent okay
let's just save it it's saying you
haven't assigned a value it is assigned
a value but never use
so
we are gonna use it now okay
now inside this container
I'm gonna write
profile info Dev
close it
now we have to add the image also
so that we are using this
profile
okay the spelling is
fine image
so it's
okay
let's write so first close it
and let's write the source of the image
so the source of the image is
which photo should I put in okay
let's write this profile dot jpeg
okay
let's
write here
slash
it's inside the profiles folder
so I'm gonna write profile
profile
photo
dot v g
and it's closed
now
boom as you can see
here is the small logo okay let's give
it a piece more
it's just first reduce the size of this
window
so we can just
see the output right
now we cannot see there it's
not good so let's now
some things with the CSS
yeah 40 would be fine
yeah 40 oh let's ride now for this line
I think 40 is fine yeah
let's give some spacing here
this would be more
so let's write
15
yeah 15 is perfect
a logo of image
is also little small
is fine
other images like this only
okay it's fine it's fine
yeah as you can see let's insert the
other side it's not looking very good
40 was fine with four one
yeah
so
as I have already told you you have to
add this four logos okay
the
icons
let's remove this
let's
work on the contacts part
let's see this first
yeah it's okay fine
let's move ahead
now we'll work on this search bar okay
search box container or search bar
let's write here
let's first just close it
yeah
after this only we have to write
another const
ant antenna no container
search
box
search box
style Dot
depth
back deck
and
background color or the background
should be
it was that F6 here
F6 and let's give it some padding
a little one
10 pixels
close it
you have to declare it here
yeah
everything is look good
yeah let's create this here
search box
inside the search box
um I'll give another
spaced
add the container
const
contact list component
here no
search container will write
container
style dot if
backtech
background
which is again the same
F6 F6 F6 here
again depending of 10 pixels we could
have copied it but
right now
forgot
let's head right
in the search
container
remove this space for the clean code
everything looks nice let's
see
looks good
okay
fine
let's give more styling here
yeah so what we're going to do is
first thing let's first just write the
flex part here
then the direction of the flex which is
row
because it's a search bar
okay
the background color we have already
declared but I'm gonna write White
because that is not matching with the
original one
or the radius I'm gonna give
16 pixels yeah
width I'm gonna write
100
and
percent
okay
yeah the padding is fine
let's write five from the right corner
yeah everything's looking good
now as you can see here you can find the
little search kind of thing
yeah to give it another face color only
what is not looking fine
now it's just blur
a little I can see
yeah
a little little I can see
now it's just as of now let's write it
white only
and let's
give it a little space in check
yeah 25 yeah fine
that's the padding of 10 is not fine I
guess
hmm
yeah it's looking fine now right as you
can see a little white box here
about the text
okay let's move forward
and let's write here icon
just the search icon that we need
to make it look more
as you can see
so the container is done yeah
I'm going to write
which is
const
shh
shh on search
icon
again
style Dot
image
back tag and let's give it a little
width
of 20
[Music]
pixels
and
height will be same again
20 pixels
close it as you can see it's showing an
error
because we have to declare it
so where we're gonna declare it
here
let's try it
the search icon
search icon source
just click close it
okay
looks fine what happened here
that's what I'm saying it's giving me
some editor
the line got deleted
no issues will again like that
const
ant on that
list
we have
search icon
style Dot
image
impacting
we're getting 27
right here we're given again 27.
array
let's close this and save it
and here inside this
I was writing
no search icon
inside the search icon I'm gonna write
source
the images
uh
icon
dot SVG
no
but
um
let's find
okay let's close it and see what's
not showing me the image the
icon
let's see
this is right
everything just looks good I don't know
why it's not
getting okay fine let's find out now
this is what coders do find out the
problems
so
found the mistake
yeah
as you can see a little search logo
let's give it some space
30
and 30.
you're looking very big no we don't need
that
so let's
face
25 and 25 only
because
okay let's
28 and 28 again
yeah
let's write here also
20.
this is looking good
let's write the padding
left
was then so no it's not left yeah
yeah this is looking good
a little change maybe but this is also
looking very good hmm yeah
now inside this search box
you have to write this
right
so what we're going to do is open the
code
after the icons
I'm going to create one another const
search
not let's write input
Style
dot input
move it to give
100 percent
okay let's find error it's fine I know
watching error
after that let's hear only right
search input
holder so placeholder is used in the
JavaScript or any other language to add
the text inside the code okay so the
placeholder will exactly copy the code
or the thing you have written inside
this curly bracket and paste it over the
page
so I'm going to write
search or start new chat right
okay it's
coming in a Bracken we don't need that
we'll remove it
so let's go back here
inside the input
let's write outline
you don't need
for the
we don't need
yeah
this is what we wanted
right
is this looking cool
yeah completely [ __ ] fine
coming back to the main part
no
let's increase the size as it's showing
very big
how to
increase the size is 15.
left
then pixel
this is looking good
right
yeah amazing
forward
now what we're going to do is we're
going to add the name component you
don't want to add this archit because it
will be very big
here so rather we'll just start with the
name components
now it's the time to delete this
yeah
so let's begin and cut this part
here
let's again okay close it
so what we're going to do is
I'm going to create another
style component and let's name it as con
Dot
component
yeah contact component
here
will be very different from the others
because here
we have to do so many other things so
let's return
con
start
component
let's
coming back to the code
okay
let's here create
attack
item
and let's copy this text
paste it inside this and let's save it
okay okay I know
this is very
irritating
now let's just complete this one
okay
it's fine
let's create another contact component
now
and that
okay
in this contact item
let's contact item is written
okay
now what we're going to do is
let's create another const
ant
contact
item
style dot Dev
game to back text
now inside this
I'm gonna write the name component
which is
display which is flex
and then
the flex Direction
yeah what's the
what's the item here okay it's fine
it's
it's seven
yeah click on that component here
now
this is fine
the return element
yeah
let's give it a wait now
width
of 100 percent
save it
contact
item
let's write border
bottom one pixel is fine
which is solid
and F2 F2 F2
now let's save it
we are now going to create this
component yeah
and coming back to the code
to this I'm going to write the
background color
which is white
I suppose
the cursor is pointer
yeah
everything's fine
now
coming back to the
now let's create the profile icon
again we'll create one const
file
icon
which will be placed like the image
style dot Dev
oh no it's here we'll write the
profile which because we need to add the
image here
again back take starts
will give width
of
38 pixels
height of 38 pixels
let's just
okay the cursor
pointer yes
let's give it a bedding here
on this
icon only
profile icon let's copy this part
let's
add the image
which will come here
so what we're going to do is we're gonna
remove this
part
and let's write
the profile
image
the source of the image
is
profile and the image down and we'll use
this this profile
file
photo
Dot
JP EG
let's close it
still getting in an error
let's see
yeah let's save it first
it's
getting us this icon
like this right
but what we're gonna do is we're gonna
add the
placeholder here
so
this is what
now we're gonna do the contact info
coming back to the code
here after this profile icon
okay
again create one another
const of contact
info
and then
tile.dev
again
display
Flex
Direction
and the width that we're going to give
it
is
100 percent
and let's close it
now
let's write another one for
contact name so let's just copy this
component
paste it here
this is contact info and this is contact
name
here I'm gonna write span
and the width
is 100
after that you will write the font
size
the font size I'm going to write is 16
pixels
to that
I'm gonna give it a color
of the text which is black
which is black
it's not
getting it let's see
issue
font size is 16.
okay
okay
so
that's seven
assign but now used it's fine
Let's scan copy one more
and add here const
message
h text
okay
Style
dot span
let's write back deck here
and give it some styling
like width is 100
after that the font size
is 14 pixels
the margin that we're going to give on
top is three only
and the color which will be using is
with the help of RGB
and it'll be zero zero zero
and 0.8
it's fine yeah
let's close it
and after here
we're gonna write another const let's
just complete the code
and then I'll
tell you okay
let's cut it
now
let's face some other things that we're
gonna use
contact info
okay let's
just delete this
right
let's just save it it's saying so many
things that we have used but never used
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
use them again
okay
let's see what's the issue up here
yeah this is closed
yeah
make the use of this contact info
the image we have already put in let's
make it a little more clean
here after the contact info
here we'll write the contact info
after that
let's write the name of the person
that
name
let's write my name here
okay
it's showing but it's just from a little
problem I guess
let's see
find out the problem
okay
okay yeah
okay
in the email you have put in
from the folder but it's not
taking the input
now we have created this
one component of name
so as you can see it's also
excellently using Plex
now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna copy this part
and paste it
let's save it and as you can see it's
showing
yeah let's save it here
now the one side of the okay this
one is a little extra
let's give it a little tin
19 is fine so this
and keep the container should be
not exactly 80.
it's right 95 is fine for it
to be precise 94.
yeah that's and uh
same line now
so let's move forward
and see
now with the text part you are done
let's work on the time part
let's open the code again
and inside the Clone
contact component
I'm gonna write message
after the info that we have created
right now only message text
and then say the message text I'm gonna
write
hello from
simply learn
again
and this is not right
contact we don't need this
okay
this I can write on
here
and here
I'm gonna write
let's read
10 or 4.
give it yeah
it's taking some of the space here
so let's
cut the space
and
find out the problem
foreign
container here yeah
this one
got that search box display it's right
here
display
s
okay
so
we have to add
display
contact one
which you have written here only
and let's reduce the width here
this one I guess was the issue
no it's not the issue here
it's just taking so much of betting
from
yeah this was fine
Style live
here
I'm gonna remove
this okay this is fine
then it's good
so
I have done few edit here like I have
given this width 20
so with the help of this the time is
coming on the correct side okay like
here you can see the time
isn't it looking like exactly like
what's up
yeah okay
let's do some more editions here
okay now
we're going to work on the container
component
let's leave the placeholder for now this
one or an image you can add here
WhatsApp one only let's make it after
some time but let's make this component
first the image and the chat component
okay
so
let's do that
coming back to the code
let's open the
conversation section
here
first we are going to create a
selector so let's add this
okay
background color will give
no
no it was done
F6 F7
and if it
let's give full background
color
now
what we're gonna do is
we're gonna add the const
profile photo
all right profile
let's
head up
and again the style.dev
let's delete it
and add some
styling
so first one is always Flex
and the direction
it's row
after that okay let's just return it
inside this container I'm gonna write
after this
profile header
and let's just
copy this and paste it
there
okay yes
remove it because we don't need that
yeah
so
what we're going to do is
let's create
the
let's hit add the
name
okay the profile header first I think
we're gonna need is the image
so I'm gonna add the image here which
will which is under
profile folder
inside that
let's add the image as
IMG
three four six four
not
PG
okay let's even
I'm checking there it's a no issue
because I'm gonna write the name inside
this
okay
the image source is correct
and then
with the return should have this
placeholder
file header is creating an issue let's
find out
okay the first thing was container
inside the container it was profile
header
then the profile here to have the image
which it will fetch and then the name
and then the profile header is closing
yep profile
header
after that container is getting closed
and the end we have declared that
okay let's find out the issue
so
this was the mistake
let's save it
still we can see uh entered here
so let's find out the error
it is const
conversation component
and inside this
we're returning the same container
with the profile header
I'll head there
okay first let's just complete this part
then we'll work on that
let's give it a background color
Ted
I think
10 pixels here
after that we will work on the
file
image
style Dot
image
it let's evaluate 32 pixels
if let's solve it right then we'll
change that
height and
the Border radius which is
50 only
okay
let's just show this
now
let's align this
Center
after that
let's give it a Gap a little
10 pixels would be fine
as you can see there is a little tab
here
yeah
looking fine
so
let's create another
chat box
right Style
dot Dev
thick
and inside this
I'm gonna write display
which is flex
background
images
F0 X 0.
bad thing I'm gonna give
off 10 pixels
and then the line item
is
Center
let's just save it let's just call this
one
after this header
Okay so
we'll chat box
after this
I'm gonna write
bottom
zero
it's not fetching it let's just wait a
couple of minutes
okay
let's see the output here
okay
export
coming back to contact list components
here I'm gonna write here
this one
let's export this part
in this also we need to export
the yeah
so we can use it on the other file
now let's even
coming back to
another file let's import this file
so
we can
use
this search
container and
the
input
let's search it
let's find out that we need to search
input yeah
okay now we are going to use it
right
so we are going to use it inside the
chat box
that would be yeah inside this
so I'm going to write search
container
and inside the search container I'm
gonna write
search
input
and
will close it
here
yeah this one is the
this part that's fine
coming back to the code
let's just give a moment
window function is working fine
everything looks
okay
yeah
maybe things looks good
now coming back to here
I'm gonna copy this placeholder or just
write it here
let's write
placeholder
type message
save it
okay
now we're gonna make the use of
more the icons
so I'm gonna write
const
emoji
it
Style
dot image
width
we're gonna give it a little
T would be fine
I think I'm gonna give it
28 pixels
okay
and then I'm gonna give it
send T which is 0.4
now
we're gonna use the data CVG inside this
container I'm going to use it
so let's write
Emoji image
source
data
CT
okay what's you have to write it inside
them
save it and see yeah
it's looking amazing
coming back to the code
inside this I'm gonna give it
here okay so here
say the search input I'm going to give
it the margin
to let the left
so I'm just gonna write 10 pixels
wait
save it and see the output now yeah it's
looking good
let's just move on
I think the box is okay it's fine fine
coming back to the code
here
after this I'm going to write cursor
just pointer
after that
this is fine I'm gonna create another
const
um
container
where all the messages will be stored
okay
style Dot
diff
icult
display
legs
then the direction
as you all know react is a beautiful
language
you can create wonders with the help of
react Library
just learn a little bit about JavaScript
HTML CSS JavaScript is the main part and
the CSS HTML is easy
great
so I'm gonna write height
which is 100
okay you can also take up any course if
you like to pursue web development we
have multiple courses on the scale up
platform
the link will be in the description box
you can just click on the link of skill
up there you will find so many other
courses for just for free
okay
so let's move on
yeah
okay
container is here
so after the profile should be placed
container
let's save it and see yeah everything's
looking good now
wait
pointer
and yeah
this is started looking really good
okay
now let's create another
const
ant let's write write it
message
foreign
Style
dot Dev and giving it
this display
should be Flex
and then again the margin
let's write margin of 5 pixels and
16 pixels let's save it
it will just give this a little brief
inside this container I'm gonna place
this
message Dev
yeah
let's save it now it's working fine
yeah
looks good
going back to the code
I'm gonna add the chart components here
okay
so
after this one
and
I'm gonna
create another
accounts
message
and say this
dialed dot div
Max width
50 pixels
that's right
percent
and the color of the
30 30.
yeah
showing its
so we can have to fetch this
is completely give the painting here
of 8 pixel and
10 pixel
save it
okay
enter this style.dev I'm going to give
background
color d a F 8 C B plus
yeah after that Max to width of this
because we can just adjust the
page
so we have to give the max width
let's give it 50 percent
okay
color I'm gonna give this
again 30 30.
search
okay it was not in this
it
and
here let's add this
let's just cut this part
and this part
and here I'm gonna give a little
width is fine
width background
color we have Kevin burning and the font
size we have to give
so I'm gonna give it
a little font size of 14 at least fine
okay
14 is fine here
let's just save it the message component
we haven't used yet
so
first we need to
using
now I'm gonna add the text
so inside this
message that we have created this now
I'm gonna write
hello
how are you
just save it and see the output boom
so it's saying hello how are you you can
also adjust the font of this and let's
make it as 19 for now
yeah 19 is
you can't see it but
19 is way better than
so hello how are you
this is looking really good
we can add as much of
you cannot
oh what we're gonna do is
we're gonna copy this component
and paste it
okay let's save it and see
yeah
back to the code
inside this container or the dev
I'm gonna use is your
is equals to True function
then
message which is
yours is equals to
so we need to add this function
here also save it
just copy this part
add this in the
message div component which is here only
okay
I'm gonna add one more thing in the
message div part
which is
justify content
flexing
yeah let's see now
so
this is coming in the
this part
this is really a good looking amazing
right
so we need to add one function also but
this is a demo so we're not going to add
that
okay
because just
change this to and to start only
and see now
yeah
right it's working fine
now we will add one function
dollar
props we're going to use here
at this I'm going to write props
is your which we have created
inside the message part
is yours question mark
and then let's close it
okay
showing one error
so what we're gonna do is
um
more thing here
from here
and here I'm inside the single brackets
let's compare this
and then
let's write here
click Start
or
Flex
end
it's
should work yeah
hello how are you
how are you
you can't add into the text right now
but
we'll do that also no worries
right
now what we're gonna do is
you're gonna copy this line
paste it
inside this
save it let's see
let's just copy this color from here
rather writing flexing I'm gonna write
okay it's just to stick let's just
copy this
paste it
copy it
paste it
here
we're going to write
not green just White
which come under
not like that
it should come in the curly brackets
note
saying again the power server
okay
this was maybe because I'm still writing
this space here
I'm going to delete the background from
here
yes
this
right
on the background color but
and next
maybe it's not fetching it right
I'm gonna make it use it
props is under
close here
here also
improps open and closing statement has
here
now let's see
is there any difference no
let's find out what's the issue
okay
so I'm going to use this prop again
it should also come under this
okay
prompts flexing start
located
inside this this is justify continent
this is background for that
not for Justified
background
now it should work
yeah thank God
it is working clearly really good
now we're gonna add one file which I
already have
wrote
so let me just copy that
so I have added one file as data.ts
so this is the content of that file I
have
wrote some names this is for the demo
purpose
so
let's just move forward
you can just
see the file
which is created
okay
I'm gonna add the file
here
the port
that list
from data let's just save it contact is
defined but never used
okay
so we're going to use this contact list
but here
okay
let's just write here
we don't need these many so I'm gonna
delete it
okay
there's so many
so
I'm gonna write one container
let's write it
here
contact list
Dot
mapping
I'm going to use
that
component
with this mapping
I'm going to add
I'm gonna use the fatter function
this is Boom
hello hello hello hello hello how are
you
it's still not catching the data that I
have provided
no issues I'll just write down
but just let's make it a little clean
okay
container of that function okay it's
should have used the brackets
so I'm gonna write here
user data
okay
here
I'm gonna call that user data
user
data
inside the curly brackets
yeah
is a complete function
we're also inside the contact component
I'm gonna write
to that
right
const
user data as props
okay
yeah it's good
the contact I haven't wrote here
okay
I should have
put this root here
here I have to put it
props not here
here
isn't available now we used okay
use it
at this
now you'll see one magic
all the names will be different another
so
I'm gonna again go back to our code
and just
use for profile picture
let's just delete this part because
I'm gonna write the function here
user data
dot profile
cool
let's check it was profile back or the
profile back here
let's now give the correct path of the
images
or let's see the images
it's not coming correct
so
let's go back to the code
and see whether it is profile pic or
let's see
a clone
so inside the public
here
you just find out
now we'll see the output and it's
showing two images but the two is not
coming so let's just see the issue
what's up with these
okay
so
the issue here is
this only
right
yeah
now let's save it and see the magic
Anjali picture is also coming now but
the commercial pack is not coming
so we'll find out why
this is happening
so
let's again go through okay the image of
this one
is jpg not PNG so
you need to change the extension
EG let's save it and now boom
see the magic
so the basic structure of WhatsApp has
been created for you guys and you can
see
it's coming very good okay
guys we have edit few steps here like I
have added one message list map function
so inside that I'm using the message
data which is inside this
which is I I man hey man what's going on
bro Baba let's go out no bro these are
the demo text that I have put
so as you can see this is the structure
message lead structure hello the sender
ID 0 0 is the person who is the first
person in the first and the one is the
second person then again the hello
what's up all good what about you is the
second person is saying I'm good what
about you and the first person is again
saying I'm good as well if this is the
conversation they have and the subscribe
to Simply learn is the message they all
want to know
so this is how the structure of the
isn't it looking amazing
right it's looking like really like
WhatsApp
as you can see guys
I know there are some editions that I
know you can guys can do like I have
told you about to add these icons I have
told you where to find it how to do it I
have showed you but I don't want you to
copy it from me I just want you guys to
do a little things that will improve
your coding skills you can just add some
see some reference from our Channel we
have so many other videos
so with this I think we have read the
end of this video If you like this video
just like the button comment on the
down and please subscribe to Simply
learn
for more such content and be safe and
please quote
so I am sure you enjoyed watching this
video
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you